[Music]
in the mid-1980s
a philosopher by the name of dr james
carse
wrote a little book called finite and
infinite games
and in it he defined these two kinds of
games
a finite game is defined as known
players fixed
rules and an agreed upon objective
football baseball
there's always a beginning middle and an
end then if there's a winner
there has to be a loser then there are
infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players
which means new players can join the
game at any time
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game
as long as possible we are players in
infinite games every day of our lives
there's no such thing as being number
one in your marriage no one ever wins
career there's no winning global
politics
you can come in first in the time you're
in school but you can't win education
and there's definitely no such thing as
winning business
but if we listen to the language of so
many leaders
it becomes abundantly clear that they
have no idea the game they're playing in
they talk about being number one being
the best and beating their competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon objectives
time frames or metrics and this is a
problem
because when we play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game
when we play to win in a game that has
no
finish line there's a few very
predictable
and consistent outcomes the big ones
include
the decline of trust the decline of
innovation
and the decline of cooperation
i'm enamored by the concept of the
infinite game
so much so that it profoundly changed
the course of my life and i ended up
building upon dr kars's work and writing
my own book
about how to actually build and maintain
an infinite mindset
dr kars sadly passed away in september
of 2020
but i had a chance to talk to him over
the summer
and i wanted to share that conversation
with you
for a couple of reasons one because he's
absolutely wonderful and remarkable and
fun
and two because i think his work is
really valuable in this day and age
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
dr jim carson yes is
so damn exciting for me you are what the
kids say these days the o.g
you are the original
[Laughter]
you know i read your book finite
infinite games
many many years ago and it so profoundly
influenced my view and change my view of
the world
and i remember i wrote you an email in
2014 just to thank you and say how much
i was a fan
you resplended two weeks later
and said thanks
[Laughter]
all those years later i i then wrote the
infinite game
based on your what i think of as a truth
you know there are a lot of people in
the world who have theories about
what the world looks like and how does
it they're just that they're theories
but there are very few people maybe once
in a lifetime that come across and put
something out there that is a truth like
biology or physics
and your understanding of finite
infinite games
it's a truth it's just fundamentally
true
how did you come up with this idea
of the concept of the into the game for
one thing
i i had a very kind of competitive
athletic type
childhood my dad was a professional
athlete he was a boxer
and so you know the family life was
full of kind of it wasn't violent but it
was
it was act very active very competitive
and i was more or less confu
comfortable with it not completely and
then went to
college and realized that i was not
cut out for some kind of acute
competitive uh profession uh once i got
into
completely into the academic world and i
found myself really very
comfortable in that world i didn't
realize i you know growing up i never
thought of being a
teacher or a professor professor but
once i got there i thought oh man i'm
home
and uh and so i i loved it
and so immediately playing with ideas
well i realized we sat around once a
week
uh you know 12 or 15 of us from
different
disciplines in the faculty talking about
game theory and i realized
uh after a while they were what they
were talking about
was winning or losing a game uh
or maximizing their their their winning
and
minimizing their losses if they weren't
playing they weren't talking about
playing the game
which i thought was interesting so i
mean the
idea of play itself suddenly appeared to
me to be a very complicated notion
uh nothing simple at all so i i wrote a
paper i did my part in the seminar
making a distinction between the finite
and for the
uh type of play uh they didn't like it
it is such a profound idea you know when
i first tripped over the idea i was
somebody gave me a copy of your book
that's how i learned about it
and at the time i was doing some work
with some folks in the military
and we we found that to be unbelievably
useful in discussing long-term strategy
um yeah because because so much of of a
foreign policy strategy
and military strategy is finite finite
finite but there is a
an infinite component to all of this and
the problem is was
we were as a nation developing all of
our infrastructure based on one mindset
which is a finite mindset and ignoring
the incident
and it was so it was so profound for
everyone i shared this with because it
as you said it completely changes the
way you not only do your work but how
you live your life
slash forward many many years later i'm
telling my sister about this as i'm
writing my book and we started talking
about how in an infinite game there's no
such thing as winning or losing
there's only a head and behind
everything is that's right
it's not going to last and if you're
behind it's not going to last yeah yeah
right
and she tried it on her son she so i
have a little nine-year-old
nephew oh very very competitive little
kid he gets very very angry when he
loses
and she my sister went to watch one of
his football games and
he he scored a losing touchdown and
uh was very angry and they lost the game
the team lost the game
and any other parent would have
dispensed with the standard parenting
advice you know it doesn't matter who
wins or loses
but my sister didn't give that advice
she said to him
it's okay you had a behind day today and
another time you're having a head day
which was the advice you gave to him so
he he realized that his loss
was temporary yeah good good no that
wasn't though that worked
well you know i noticed that with my own
children i
you know three kids and i noticed a lot
of difference in their play when they
were playing something like
you just talked about a softball game or
ping pong or anything you know no one
was quite happy at the end
you know everyone was a little bit
unhappy even the winners
they thought they could have done better
you know but then when they got into the
games where they made it up
as they went along they could play
something all day long
people you know kids would come over
sometimes i'd go play with them or my
wife would or
whatever you could go in and out of the
game and keep going and it was just a
very very different kind of
environment different climate of a
different way
that they related to each other and i
thought wait a minute this is this is
worth writing down
it plays to the idea of ethics as well
doesn't it because when you're playing
in an infinite mindset like if you're
doing lego or you're building something
or you're drawing as you said some
creative pursuit that your kids were
doing
it necessarily generates creativity
with the finite generates strategies
only to win which can
which can sometimes lead to some rather
unethical uh choices
there's no really unethical choices when
you're making lego
you know yeah yeah right that's true
well you know
that's an important point in a way
because when you're in
in a finite game the ideal of
you know when you're doing your best
it's because
you've already figured out what to do
in other words your big decisions are
behind you
not ahead of you so you know this is
going to be your strategy this is what
you're going to do when
that person does this and so on so all
of your
all of your moves are thought out first
but when you're an infinite game
you you wait to see what the thoughts
are as you move into the
into the situation so it's you're always
you're always dealing with the kind of
in in other words your eyes operating
with a certain degree of novelty
that you you will not necessarily use in
a finite game
i need to say that again that is so good
in a finite game all your best thinking
is behind you
and now it's simply the the muscle
memory or the application
of all of that thinking that's right
whereas in the infinite game
all the best thinking has yet to come
and you have no choice but to step into
the unknown
right and that's unnerving for a lot of
people the [ __ ] yeah
i think a lot of people are finite not
because it's better but because it's
it's either easier or at least it's more
tangible see
that's what i saw with these guys in
that discussion that faculty group
they didn't like they were sort of
allergic
i the ways that i felt about it allergic
to play
because once you're in if it's really
play
you you what's lying ahead of you is
still unformed
yeah but so so the ideal of a of a
finite player that what every finite
player tries to do
is in effect win the game before you
start it know exactly what you're gonna
do every move you're gonna make
and and the game is just an illustration
of what you've
just a kind of demonstration of what
you've already figured out
so that uh it's like playing in the past
you you have uh you're like you're
playing something you've already made up
and decided to do
rather than playing inventively
creatively
imaginatively and so on i need you to
unpack something for me so i understand
that the infinite game is not the
absence of finite games
it's the context within which finite
games might exist that's right
you can absolutely have wins and losses
within
uh the pursuit of something greater for
sure but but the thing that i'm
that i i need you to help me understand
because i don't
is when it's the reverse so for example
the a marine once told me a u.s marine
once told me that no plan
ever succeeds contact with the enemy
right
in a finite game in a in a battle where
there is a winner and a loser
and there's a there's a beginning middle
and end it is it's finite
explain that to me where the creativity
lies in front of them
because as soon as you have contact with
the enemy who's got very different plans
everything goes
sideways or is that just like chess
which is you you should prepare for all
of the different variations just riddle
me back just walk me through
okay let's go through that again you see
now now no
a warrior trains for is to have
a perfect response to every move the
enemy makes
yeah so you you you are planning not to
be
surprised you want to know everything
the enemy can possibly do
now of course intelligent military
planners
know that the enemy is also human and
they're going to they're going to have
their own imagination
and they're going to do something that
will surprise you so you
you the whole goal is to minimize the
degree of surprise
and so that's what that's what the
military terry trains you to do
uh to uh to reduce that that margin
you know that surprise yeah uh in there
and
and uh that's why there's so much
training that's why when you go in the
military that's all there is
but you could say that for everything
right every finite an athlete
yeah yeah it's all to minimize the
surprises
yeah right yeah i remember you know i
i spent hundreds of hours on a football
field
trying trying to to uh get myself not to
be surprised by what some other guy did
yeah or i mean but it seems i'm just as
you're talking i'm running all the
finite games through my mind school you
know where there's a beginning
middle and end to the school year you
get a grade it's yeah
it's the same thing you wanna you study
to minimize the surprises on the test
exactly exactly yeah right right oh this
is so good
yeah how did you learn an infinite
mindset was it innate or
is it something that you have to train
for well the way i see it is that
an infinite player infinite players
prepare themselves
to be surprised yeah so you expect
surprise yeah uh and and uh
rather than find you know trying to keep
it from happening
so so you set up a situation that's
bound to to develop in a way
you you can't anticipate that's what in
a way that's the way a poem
a poet a poet starts a poem as a as a
great first line or i'll bet you start
you've started books that way yeah you
have
you have a chapter you really like an
idea you really like
you you put it down the next thing you
know this comes that comes that goes
are you still susceptible to to finite
to slipping into the finite oh hell yes
yeah i know i actually i i'm
i'm pretty competitive you know you
can't you can't
go through a life as i have without
being
you know a whole bunch of degrees and
honors and
uh appointments and you know
advancements and so on without being
competitive
so uh you know i'm happy to admit that
and enjoy doing it along the way i'm
hugely exclusive
you know it's very important to keep
that distinction in mind that
that what's important about a finite
game is that it's it it occurs within a
larger
context within the everything in the
game yeah and
i i'm i'm a great promoter of finite
gains i mean i think they're
they're important there are a lot of
reasons why you'd play a finite game
but how to how did i get there i'm not
sure i think it was
yeah i would describe the process as
more osmotic
than i would uh kind of step by step you
know it kind of
poked in and the more i looked around
the more i well what happened
uh simon i would say it this way once
the idea got
sort of clear in my head i saw it
everywhere
yeah as the master of the infinite
mindset
what is your take on on this current
situation with the pandemic
with a pandemic well what i think is
that we are now in a position where we
can do some really good
long-distance thinking and and and step
back and look at
all these things we're doing sort of
abstract ourselves from them for a while
uh do we do we really want to spend our
lives doing what we've been doing
do we want really want the kind of
government the kind of society the kind
of
technology the kind of this the kind of
math that we have
it's a good time to look at it it's a
good time to to do a little
infinite thinking yourself you know
where how far
are we going with it and as a matter of
fact i i think i mentioned to you i've
already written a book about that
yes sir which i'm keen to read well i
i've got
i've got a first draft i'm hesitating to
show it to anyone yet but
it'll get there and and and uh but
that's but
that's what i'm trying to say that that
now
this gives us a marvelous opportunity as
i put it
to find a new way through the
approaching the one thing we know about
this this
this pandemic is there's only a mild
version
of what's going to happen when the
environment crashes
yeah i mean it's going to be horrible
really there's there's no way of getting
around it
you know it's so funny you talk about
the environment which is even
it's well intentioned but even the
messaging for climate change has been
very finite oriented
oh very very people you know people talk
about we're killing the planet
no we're not no planet the planet will
be fine the planet
life is infinite it will find a way
through all we're doing is killing
ourselves
as i don't have to tell you in the in
the finite game
it's the game that ends but the player
continues to live
in the infinite game it's it's the
player that ends that drops out of the
game is
the game
climate change is destruction of our own
species
the planet's fine oh yeah there that
gives a damn
right yeah right you said something
that i want to read back to you that is
because i you obviously you you're
you've had a long and storied career you
you've done much more work than just the
infinite game out of curiosity which is
your favorite book that you've written
whoa whoa uh you know i i i
have a hard time with that one uh i'm
not sure i think
probably the book on belief this is the
the religious case against the case
against belief yeah
a religious case against belief which
you know i've made a career out of
talking about
the importance of belief
how do you define belief well
what what interests me is that
characteristic of belief
you know the kind of it's the true
believer i'm targeting
the person says this is the way i see it
this is
it this is the end of the discussion and
so on but
um of course i always have to go back to
the greeks now the greeks had
made a distinction between knowledge
which you know which is true and you
uh the gnosis that that you know
it's like you're saying it is a truth
and it's obvious uh truth
you don't have to believe it you know it
it's in your head it's already working
there
you don't have to defend it it's it
stands by itself
and that they they oppose that to doksa
which is opinion
yeah we use that we use that word and
the phrase
orthodox orthodoxy meaning right opinion
you know having an opinion and for the
most part when people talk about their
beliefs
i think the way you're talking about it
it's more like an opinion
this is the way i see it if you have an
argument against that
i'll entertain the argument but so far
this is my opinion about that subject
well that's one thing but but when
people say i believe
in this person or that thing or that
movement that idea
uh then i i i'd see it as
the point where you've turned your
thinking off
now the one thing about about serious
believers
usually they come in a system there's a
system of thinking that goes with it
that uh in addition to the the mere
idea or the belief itself or the opinion
itself
uh so they come in systems but what a
what a
a critical thinker would do is question
the system itself
rather than then a belief in it you know
belief based on it so you you begin to
look at all the assumptions that led you
to that belief
and so on but believing for me has a
negative
that's why there's i make a religious
case against it because
it is it's where your thinking stops
it's where
wonder stops aristotle said at one point
philosophy
begins in wonder it's a great phrase
i like to think of religion as something
that ends in wonder
not in belief so uh
you know that's my my sort of my grand
definition of religion if i have one
i do so love this idea that belief is
where
thinking ends and that if we have
beliefs
it is okay to have beliefs but to be
closed
to challenging our own beliefs or to
your to your point of system
is important and if we still cling on to
those beliefs
we should we should know the reasons why
that's right
right we should know the reasons why and
it could be something
it could be nostalgic it could be
because that's how it was with my
parents and i want to continue that
legacy
but i think to be able to explain why i
hold on to a belief
without a criticism of someone who holds
a different belief yeah and that's
i think that's very hard to do it's much
easier to it's much easier to define
what we believe in by saying what we
believe against well as a matter of fact
most believers
are they have a whole i mean everything
on their side is matched by something
negative on the other
yeah so so it's like uh two systems
these are beliefs these are unbeliefs
you know and and they they
and so that's why i i consider myself
neither a believer nor unbeliever
um you know being an academic that's not
too hard
you know it's it because for example
just take
any any big intellectual category uh
theory of uh evolution
now if you're if you're a certain kind
of christian
you would say i don't believe in that
theory but if you were a scientist
a theory is not a belief it's it's a
testing
of it's an example it comes from you
know the word theory comes from the
greek word for seeing
so to have a theory is to have a vision
a sight of something
to see for yourself the way something is
so that's different than having a belief
what is your
thought as to what happened to our
society why we became
so dogmatic in our beliefs whether it's
left or right
you know they're both equally as bad
where
i'm right and you're wrong right how did
we get to the point or has it always
been this way
how do we get to the point where it
seems so exaggerated where both sides of
the aisle
you know our country's so divided where
the belief has become
the kind of truth to people yeah i i'm
just fascinated by
how your thoughts is how we got here you
know if i think in great big terms it
would be something like
we we are now entering a new age of
anxiety in a way
and there's a lot of uncertainty out
there
and so the uncertainty of a number of
kinds
number one a lot of traditional
institutions are losing their
their grip so that you you have less
guidance
less you feel that like the ground is
shifting more under you there's not a
solid place
to stand so so people are tempted to
find positions where they can just stay
there and let the world
swirl around them you know and they
don't have to question themselves
and i i think uh self-criticism is
is uh absolutely crucial to being human
to begin with but
but this is what's disappearing this is
really profound so
in times of uncertainty or when there's
a when there's a feeling of anxiety
our desire to hold on to the finite or
our desire to hold on to belief
goes up because inherent in the infinite
game i have to be open to the uncertain
but if i'm feeling
anxious the uncertainty is the thing i
do not want
exactly yeah and so and so i'm going to
ground myself in belief
because it gives me comfort right so it
seems the way
forwards is it's environmental right
it's for our leaders
to offer a sense of vision and to offer
a sense of
to offer some sense of certainty or some
sense of hope or
something that we can lock onto which
will then inherently make us all
mo more open-minded to each other but
absent that
right absent something outside us inside
us
we become more more dogmatic and more
fixed
in our beliefs and we believe even more
strongly that i am right and you are
wrong
yeah that's right that's the way it
works yeah exactly that way
and uh you know you know one thing one
feature about an infinite game
that about the whole theory in a way is
that
it's neither left nor right right it's
not
religious or irreligious it's not there
not here it's not big it's not little it
doesn't it doesn't belong into the usual
categories that people put stuff into i
mean you couldn't tell from reading my
book what my political views are for
example
in fact i don't even have political
views i i would put it this way
it's one thing to have it's one thing to
have a politics
it's another to be political i'm
political but i have no politics
explain the difference well i'm
concerned about the way a whole
society apollos operates now
there are all kinds of views about how
it should operate point is
to be political is to have a sense of
the palace
now that was that's that's what's
interesting about aristotle
he thought a philosopher is a person who
had
by definition a social conscience that
is you were concerned about what
the society you lived in now he
aristotle uh lived in a terrifically
wild crazy uh
society uh athens but he he also had a
real respect for what he called the
demos you know
d-e-m-o-s and from democracy a people
actually you can translate a lot
different ways a neighborhood or a
gathering or a
uh institution even a a country
but a demos has its own identity and
all the people in it are of it and and
think in its terms and aristotle thought
to be a really reflective person
or as he called them contemplative he
used that word
you have to be a good citizen to be
political you said something that i
think sums up
the magic that is jim cars and why i
adore you so much
and and i think it sums up this
conversation as well which is in the
sense that i am
endlessly fascinated with the
unknowability of what it means to be
human
it's it's it's it's paradoxical
it is yeah paradox is the word that's
the word yeah
it is apparently our desire for
certainty
to understand and for explanation
is we yield to the the joy of finding
explanation in that which is
unexplainable and the joy of finding
certainty and that which is uncertain
yeah it's just the most magically human
experience in the world because human
beings are
almost all aspects of our lives
paradoxical
yeah that's right yeah and well
yeah i mean i can go on for a while
please do somehow you got me hooked on
aristotle here
but but uh of course i love the guy
aristotle but
the first sentence of his metaphysics
which is
kind of the big work of aristotle uh
the first sentence goes every one every
human being by nature
has a desire to learn that's that's his
thing
now i i looked at that for a while i
thought i mean i looked at it in greek
which is
it reads a little differently in greek
and it it like
every everyone everyone born human has a
desire
a longing to see for one's self that's
really the way
i would translate that line it's
conceivable oneself yeah
you want to see it you don't want
somebody to tell you you want to see it
yourself
and that's what aristotle thought is is
what makes us
what makes us human and and and i
thought
wow that's that's a terrific insight but
what that implies
is you're never satisfied i mean one
that's why that desire doesn't die
it lives with you your whole life it's
there because
you know there's still more you haven't
seen you want you want to see it
and so you keep going at it and that's
what in the end
he he calls it as i said before he calls
it
uh contemplation it's filled with what
what he also called energea
energy which is in some definitions of
aristotle
is life itself so it's like a living
living contemplatively contemplatively
uh
and uh that seems to me to be a hot the
highest expression of our humanity
jim i adore you
i adore you i adore you you you have the
most wonderful
manner you just you're open you know i i
hold myself to the high standard of
wanting to be a more infinite minded
person and live my life with an infinite
mindset every day
and and you know i've often referred to
not just your work but to you as the
gold standard for me and so
it's an honor it's a joy to sit down
with you and talk to you thank you for
taking the time
um yeah simon this is my my pleasure as
well
i'm very happy i have you as a matter of
fact
because i i i had a long
long desire to see some of these ideas
go to work and you put it to work and i
i
very very much appreciate it i think
you've done it brilliantly thank you
uh i i thank you that means everything
to me yeah
all the best uh okay thank you give
yourself to cave those where are you
absolutely all right
i'm really glad i got to know jim cars
and have him in my life for a little bit
i'm definitely going to miss him but in
the spirit of the infinite game
i'm also proud to carry his torch and
spread his work
so that may live on way way beyond his
own lifetime
until next time take care of yourself
take care of each other